i thank god
for having granted me the privilege to
be here to be a part of this experience
and i shall long remember it and
remember you
i hope that you did not come just to
attend seminars
but you came that something may work a
change in your life
don't just sit and listen to biblical
presentations
and just go away the same person
and so my prayer for you is that
you will always walk the path of truth
at any cost what did i just say
at any cost you know jesus said
this people honoreth me with their lips
but their hearts are far from me
what the lord needs is people who will
stand for the truth
though the heavens fall as ellen white
so beautifully says
like the three hebrew boys excuse me
choosing to do right over life
if you are afraid to die for god the
devil has you
did you hear what i said as long as
you're afraid to die
for god the devil has you
because he has a weapon with which to
intimidate you and that weapon is the
threat to your life but when you come to
the place
like the apostle paul in acts 20 where
you do not hold your life dear to you
the devil has lost because you cannot
intimidate a person
who is not afraid to die
and satan knows that and so the bible
says in hebrews 2 14 and 15
for as much then as the children are
partakers of flesh and blood
he also himself likewise took part of
the same
that through death he might destroy him
that had the power of death that is the
devil
now listen to verse 15 and deliver them
who through
fear of death were all their lifetime
subject to bondage do not be afraid to
give your life
for the cause of truth i need more
amends than that
all right jesus gave his life
for sinners can you give your life
for sinless god greater love hath no man
than this finish the verse
that a man lay down his life for his
friends what does jesus say
yeah my friends if you do finish the
verse
whatsoever i command you
and so i say from the foundation of my
soul god is good
and all the time
before i begin please turn off your
phones
i will begin by turning mine off
my iphone 5.
i know i'm behind the times there's six
and six plus and seven
but this one works just fine favor
number two
while i'm speaking please pray for me
and say lord
finish it for me put your words in that
man's mouth
i don't think many people believe how
serious i am when i make that request
one wrong word can turn someone off even
if
it is the truth
one word of truth spoken at the wrong
time
what did jesus say in john 16 12 i have
yet
many things to say unto you finish the
verse he cannot bear them now
so there's something that must go along
with truth and that is
timing and that applies to a sermon
and so i want god's words in my mouth
and i want to speak them at the right
time
and the third fifth i politely request
is that you really think
as you listen to god's word let's pray
dear god in heaven we are unworthy to
come to you
and so we cling to the cross desperately
father you have to drag us from that
cross because we're not moving
we say like jacob we are not letting you
go
except you bless us and even after you
bless us we're not letting go
and so lord i ask you from my heart the
heart of a sinner
who loves you grant me your spirit
i desire no glory for myself dear god
i want you glorified before your people
but help me to do that give me your
spirit give me the right words the right
ideas the right sequence of ideas
and bless your beloved sons and
daughters who've come to listen
touch their hearts their god if there is
someone listening
who has a hard heart break down the
jericho
walls of that heart dear god that the
truth may go marching in
at the end of this presentation and this
entire weekend let us
look back and glorify your name for the
blessings you poured out on us
thank you for life thank you for christ
thank you for loving us thank you for
truth
in a world of error i pray from my heart
in jesus name
let god's people say amen and amen
our subject nothing is cheap
what did i say nothing is cheap
go with me to mark 6
we will read 7 12 and 13.
mark 6
7 12 and 13 let me clarify that mark
chapter 6 verses 7
12 and 13.
and i hope you will assign yourself the
task
of memorizing the books of the bible in
order so that you can find
is anyone here who can do that recite
all books from genesis or revelation
come sister come
come you're young come quickly
from genesis to revelation do i can i
have a microphone
please i have a lot of time it's okay
and i never take all my time
come my handsome brother bring that mic
may the lord bless you in every way
sister
genesis to revelation let's listen
genesis
exodus leviticus numbers deuteronomy
joshua judges ruth first
second samuel versus second kings first
and second chronicles
ezra nehemiah esther jobs psalms
proverbs ecclesiastes song of solomon
isaiah jeremiah lamentations ezekiel
daniel hosea joel amos obadiah
jonah micah nahim habakkuk zephaniah
haggai
zachariah malachi matthew mark luke john
acts romans first and second corinthians
galatians ephesians philippians
colossians
first and second thessalonians first and
second timothy
titus philemon hebrews james first and
second peter first second and third john
jude in revelation let the church say
amen what's your name sister
linda is a good name god bless you linda
god bless you
is there anyone else who can do that
oh the catholic bible well it has books
that are not uh
regarded by the church linder god bless
you and my sister god bless you you can
do it backward and those we can do
backward and sideways and forward
may the lord bless you i really mean
that from my heart we must be familiar
with the word of god am i right okay
god bless you and if your children don't
know how assign them the task
you'll be surprised how quickly they
will memorize
the books of the bible mark 6 what
verses did i say
12 and 13. the bible says and he called
unto him the twelve
and began to send them forth by two and
two
and give them power what over unclean
spirits the bible says verse 12
and they went out and preached that men
should do what
repent by the way the bible says if
jesus the kingdom of heaven is at hand
repent believe the gospel john the
baptist said
the kingdom of heaven is at hand repent
believe the gospel
jesus sent the disciples out they went
they preach
repent we live in an age where people
just want to hear
love the gospels message was
repent now repent involves a lot of
things
repent of what sin you must know what
sin is transgression of the law so the
law comes in
what does the law express righteousness
what does the law express
the character of jesus christ so yes to
repent you must first acknowledge you've
done wrong
so you must confess so all of that has
to be dealt with when you preach repent
but jesus sums it up in repent
with brotherly love let me say to you if
there's something you need to repent of
repent before you leave this room repent
while i'm preaching
because you do not know if you live by
the time i finish
i'm not joking never delay to repent
if there's something for which you need
to say sorry say it
while i'm speaking right now don't wait
and they went and preached that men
should repent now verse 13 and they cast
out what
many devils and anointed with oil many
that were sick finish the verse
and heal them now go back to seven and
we shall read
that verse how microscopically
and he called unto him the twelve the 12
excuse me
and began to send them forth by two and
two
and he did what gave them
now i want you to visualize jesus giving
them
now if i give you something what happens
there are three things in that
transaction
what are the three things me
or i what's the other one the third the
thing given
i was the third the receiver
do you see that in your head here's
jesus
hear the disciples jesus
gives them something
what was that power
excuse authority
in other words something left jesus
because based on verse 13 and they cast
out many devils verse 7 says
he gave them power over unclean spirits
matthew 10 verse 1 tells us the same
thing
and when he had called into him his
twelve disciples he gave them power
against evil spirits to cast them out
and to heal all men of sickness and all
manner of disease
so while mark doesn't mention the
healing of disease we know matthew tells
us that is what happened
because he's recounting the same event
jesus gave them
something now it's not something that's
three-dimensional
it's not like this earth phone it's has
weight and occupies space
but it is as real as something
three-dimensional
now i can't give you a handful of power
i've never seen power
i have seen the results of power
exercise are you with me
but what i want you to get in mind
something left
jesus he gave them some of something he
had
what was that power now they took that
power
and they commanded spirits and the
spirits obeyed
they took that power they prayed over
the sick
and the diseases were rebuked
the disciples didn't heal the power from
christ healed
so power is something real
it has a source that's god
are you with me let's go now to mark
stay in mark chapter five
what's our subject nothing is cheap
mark five we'll read from verse 25
the story is familiar the woman with the
issue of blood
do you have that the bible says and a
certain woman
which had an issue of blood how long 12
years
and had suffered many things of many
physicians
and had spent all that she had and was
nothing better it finished the verse
but rather grew worse that sounds like
modern day situations
spent a lot of money on expensive
procedures
and you're sent home to die but there's
a god that heals can you say amen
at your convenience read exodus 15 26
not now
and see the promise god has made to his
people
when she had heard of jesus came in the
press behind
and touched his garment for she said
if i may touch but his clothes i shall
be
and straightway the fountain of her
blood was dried up
read the next few words with me and she
felt in her body
that she was whole healed of that plague
now the power of jesus
worked in the woman's body she felt
that she was whole or healed of that
plague verse 30 says
and jesus immediately knowing in himself
that virtue had gone out of him stop
i want you to compare virtue going out
of him
in verse 30 with mark 7 verse 6 verse 7
and jesus gave them
on both occasions did something go out
of jesus yes or no
yes
jesus immediately knowing in himself
that virtue had gone out of him
turned him about in the press and said
who touched my clothes
and his disciples said unto him thou
seest the multitude thronging thee
and says thou who touch me and he looked
round about
to see her that had done this thing but
a woman fearing and trembling
knowing what was done in her
[Music]
she felt the effects of the working of
that power
all right let's focus let's focus please
felt the effects of that power
came and fell down before him finished
that beautiful verse
told him all the truth let me digress
briefly
do you need to come to christ and tell
him all the truth
what you've been doing
i mean all just fess up as we say
you know the policeman pulls a gun on
you what do you do
throw your hands up don't you
is this someone who needs to go to god
and tell him finish my thoughts all the
truth
father this is what i've been doing i'm
sorry
young or old middle aged tell god
all the truth he already knows
but jesus said unto her daughter thy
faith hath made thee whole
go in peace and be whole of thy plague
let's look at that incident again
particularly verse 30
and jesus immediately knowing it himself
that virtue had
gone out of him in other words
to heal that woman the healing of that
woman
came at a cost to christ
you're not convinced
to heal the healing of the woman
required
a cost from christ
what was that cost power
to enable the disciples to perform
miracles came at a cost
to christ
can we develop a general principle every
work every miraculous work of god
is a cost to him
well let's go to genesis 1 and see
something costly
what's our subject nothing is cheap
genesis 1 reading from verse 1 the bible
says in the beginning
god created the heaven and the earth now
let's go to verse three
and god said let there be light
did the light come yes or no how
the part of his work listen to hebrews 1
3 just listen who being the brightness
of his glory
and the express image of his person and
upholding all things how
by the word of his power
the word of god has power creation was
brought about
by the powerful word of god and so when
god said let there be light
that was a expression an exercise
an expenditure of what power
verse 6 and god said let there be a
firmament in the midst of the waters
and let it divide the waters from the
waters and it was so
and god made the firmament power
third day vegetation let the earth bring
forth grass verse 11
power from god of course god's
fountain of power is limitless his
reservoir is limitless
but it still requires an outflow of
power
therefore sun moon and stars day five
birds of the air
fishes of the sea the basics land
animals and of course
humanity how much power
was required to create the heavens
and the earth
let's go to psalm 148. read verses
1 2 and 5.
psalm 148 verses 1 2 and 5.
do we sister linda you should have found
it first
you have it sister linda lady who
recited
all the verses for us or the chapters if
you have it say amen
if you're still looking say amen oh come
on come on
come on let's speed it up this is the
last day we need to go home
all right verse 1 of psalm 148 read with
me what does it say
praise he the lord keep reading praise
to the lord
from the heights from the heavens praise
him in the heights
praise he him all his angels praise him
all his hosts scripture five
let them praise the name of the lord
finish the verse for he
commanded they were created
now somewhere else says the angels were
called into existence
i think she says jesus was the son of
god
he was one with the father ages before
the angels
were called into existence
what i get from that is god spoke the
angels into existence
they were called into existence the
bible says
he commanded and they were created
did that require power how many angels
are there
we don't know we don't know
thousand times thousands and ten
thousands of thousands
now we've looked at the cost to create
we can't measure that cost but listen to
colossians 1 17
and he is before all things
and by him finish the verse all things
consist
now it requires power to create
if i'm correct say amen it requires
power to what
maintain
let me reply uh recite uh read hebrews 1
3 again who being the brightness of his
glory and the express image of his
person
and upholding all things by the word of
his power
the power that creates is the power that
maintains
that's why an angel can't maintain
creation
that's why those who believe in deism
are wrong i believe deism says
god made the world and left it to run
itself
now the world that is created by divine
power
is run by divine power
i always wonder why just a few of you
say amen is it the rest of you are lost
or am i unclear probably i am listen to
me carefully
when god said let there be light and
there was light
the power that created the light is the
very power that maintains the light
now the power that created the light is
the power of god not an angel
now since it's the same power to keep
the light lighting
then it requires the same god who
created to preserve
so no angel could preserve creation
creation itself cannot preserve itself
ah you're not with me
this is a bad time to discourage a
preacher just at the end when he thought
he was making some difference
creation cannot preserve itself
because the power to preserve a created
thing is divine power
are you with me you know our one of our
founding fathers let me say that used to
believe in deism what's his name
i mean spiritual family thought of the
church and i say carefully
william miller he believed in deism eu
said notice it's it's for me it's an
expression of uh
evolution for me
the way god is not involved you see
creation cannot maintain itself and if a
person believes that
the person is regarding creation as god
and the bible talks about those who
disregard the creator and they worship
what
the creature if you say creation runs
itself
and to run to run it must be run by
divine power you are calling creation
god
and there's only one god and thou shalt
have no the gods before me
all right now it requires power from god
to create and to maintain
are you with me how much power is that
did he have any left of course
now let's go to genesis 2 verse 7.
what's our subject
nothing is cheap genesis 2 verse 7.
who can recite that without looking
come on say i said without looking
sister without looking
say
all right all right before the police
come let's say properly
and the lord god formed man of the dust
of the ground
come on and breathe into his nostrils
the breath of life
and man became a living soul now we have
we have what did god breathe into adam
life life from whom
god
did he give life to eve
why do you hesitate sometimes did god
give life to eve
yes psalm 36 9 with thee is the fountain
of life
all life comes from god plant life
animal life
human life from god nothing can live
outside of god
so those of you are going to the new
world if you think immortality means
you cut off from god you can just keep
yourself alive you are wrong
nothing can live disconnected from god
so in the new world we're still
dependent on god
for our immortal lives and so all
plant life gets life from god
all the birds get life from god all the
land creatures get life from god
every human being saved and sinner gets
life
from god now here's what we're dealing
with
god created using power
he maintains using power he's given life
to everything that lives
he did all of that without dying
yes it is god did all of that
and it did not cost him his life
it did not cost god his life to create
the universe
it does not cost him his life to
preserve the universe
let's go to genesis 2. what's our
subject nothing is cheap
we read verses 16 17 of genesis
the bible says and the lord god
commanded the man saying
of every tree of the garden thou must
freely eat you know god gives us freedom
can you say a man for freedom god really
gives us freedom let me digress again
i'll come back to genesis 2 16.
when the devil has you you have no
choice
when i say that you can't get out
in isaiah 14 17 who opened not the house
of his prisoners let me say it again
when satan has you
you may desire to leave but you cannot
leave
when god has you you can leave any time
you want
that's freedom in order to leave the
devil
god has to come get you that strong man
matthew 10 29
or 12 29 or else how can one enter the
strong man's house and spoil his goods
except he first bind the strong man and
then he will spoil his house to spoil
means to take away
what is taken away the captives of satan
as represented by the dumb and blind man
who was healed in verse 22 of matthew
12. when you're with god the devil
doesn't have to come get you you can
just leave
let me say it again there is freedom in
god can you say amen
there is choice in god and so god says
of every tree of the garden thou may
freely eat
but of the tree of the knowledge of good
and evil thou shalt not eat of it for in
the day thou eat is thereof finish the
verse
thou shalt surely die now the concept of
death
is introduced to adam who clearly
passed it on to sister eve
we know adam sinned let's go to verse 7
of chapter 3.
the bible says in the eyes of them both
were opened
and they knew that they were naked you
know there's some things god does not
want you to know
and if he wants you he'll tell you when
he's ready
some of us get into trouble because we
poke our noses in areas where we have no
business
the eyes of them both were open they
knew that they were naked
they sought fig leaves together made
themselves aprons verse 8 said
and they heard the voice of the lord god
walking in the garden in the cool of the
day
this weekend have you heard the voice of
god talking to you
have you come towards the voice or have
you backed up
the bible says they heard
voice of the lord god walking in the
garden of the cool of the day
and adam and his wife hid themselves
from the presence of the lord god
amongst the trees of the garden they
have sinned
now they cover the apron leaves in verse
seven
god gives them quotes of skins in 21
representing of course the covering of
christ
now when god gave adam life in chapter 2
verse 7
it did not cost god his life
to give life the first time are you with
me
that was part of creation now that adam
has sinned
and has died how spiritually
you see everyone who's saved is brought
back from death are you with me
does that include adam yes when jesus
told nicodemus not nicodemus zacchaeus
the son of man has come to seek and to
save that which was lost
when did he come to seek and save four
thousand years after creation no that
began in the garden
genesis 3 9 says in the lord god called
unto adam and said unto him where thou
he came to seek finish my words and to
save
ephesians 2 1 tells us and you hath he
quickened who were what
dead adam and eve were lost
every lost person is dead spiritually
now god has to give them life
to do that it cost him
finish my words his life what all
creation did not cost
the salvation of one soul cost god
more than it cost him to create and
maintain
the universe including all the angels
every living and non-living thing
counsels for the church page 121
paragraph two ellewhite writes
one soul is an infinite value
for calvary speaks its worth
listen to jesus as he tries to express
this sentiment
what man of you having 100 sheep if he
lose how many
one of them doth not leave the 9009 in
the wilderness
and go after that which was lost what's
the next word
and go after that which was lost
until now let's pause on until
look at it microscopically what does
until
mean
remember a fellow in american history
called malcolm x
the 60s black struggle he was well known
for an expression he had
who can tell me what that expression was
by any means necessary
now listen to the word doth not leave
the 99 in the wilderness
and go after that which was lost
until i will find that sheep
fill in the gap now by any
means necessary up to and
including the loss finish my words of my
life
the cost to save one sinner
actually is the cost of the universe
when you consider that can you give up
an earring for god
in the light of what we just said can
you begin to appreciate the verse that
says
how shall we escape if we neglect
so great salvation
when you say no to that kind of cost
do you not understand the proper just
right a fitting thing
as hell
until you find it i believe patriarch
not the desire of video space i think
693 paragraph three ella white writes
he will save man at any cost to himself
is our of ages page 131 paragraph two he
not only became an exile from the
heavenly courts
but for us took the risk of failure and
eternal
loss in order for her to use the word
risk it simply means
the possibility of christ being lost
existed you hear what i said
the possibility of the creator being
lost
to save me
how do i reward him by smoking
by drinking by running off with a head
deacon's wife
is that the level of my appreciation for
that kind of sacrifice
no wonder the bible says in first john 4
19 we love him
why finish the verse because as we
contemplate
the cost it does something in the bosom
it generates love as the only
appropriate response to that kind of
love
the same way life begets life love
begets love
but it has to be understood nothing my
brothers and sisters
finish the theme or the subject nothing
is cheap
and so this morning i present to you
your worth in the sight of god
express it differently god was willing
to lose jesus
that he might not lose you
now he made that decision while you and
i
were absolutely enemies of his
he didn't wait until we'd improved
ourselves and became less file
he valued us when we were filed
and that has to be applied individually
now you take that beyond yourself that's
how god values me
that's how god values your neighbor
the blood that saves the seventh-day
adventist saves a muslim
who accepts the truth the blood that
saves the highest man on earth
saves the wino in the gutter
and so this contemplating this enormous
truth not only changes us
with respect to our relationship to god
it must change us with regard to our
relationship to one another
when you abuse someone you're abusing
something that god values
when you get on the church board and try
to sabotage someone's appointment to an
office
you're doing that to someone god values
above everything else
when you get on the phone and gossip
you're gossiping about a pearl that god
values
angels in heaven are not as close to god
as we are
because of
did jesus hear what i said hebrews 2 16
for verily he took not on him the nature
of angels
he took on him the seat of abraham jesus
did not become an angel to come die for
us
and in the new world he will always have
his human flesh
always looking like us not them
now god bless the angels don't
misunderstand me i'm alive because god
has
ordered his angels to protect me i look
forward to seeing the angel assigned to
me
and he's standing somewhere over here or
wherever he's standing or sitting but i
want to see him
but truth is truth through jesus christ
we have a closeness with god that the
angels don't have
that adam did not have
do you understand what i'm saying
where's jesus sitting
are we risen with christ by faith
where do we sit in jesus where do the
angels sit
where do they not sit on the throne
no wonder every failure of god's
people's result of lack of faith
when you accept this you believe this
you don't wait for someone to have
confidence in you
you know who has confidence in you god
my brothers and sisters let me close the
book as evidence i'm coming to the end
god the creator loves you
and he told he tells us every say every
week take a special day
that i have chosen the seventh and
contemplate
how valuable you are to me
every sabbath he says go for a walk
somewhere as you look at the tree
the skies the sun remember
they are cheap compared to what you're
worth to me
when you read of all the gold that's
mine out of south africa all the
diamonds from botswana
that these things prop up world
economies
you look up and you say father all that
gold
all those diamonds combined all the
pearls from the
the oceans are cheap compared to the
value of place where
on me
and so the sabbath is a reminder that
god
values us above everything
and everyone and what god values
he wants with him
and so today will you not consciously
deliberately intentionally purposefully
and willfully recommit your life to god
will you not confess that sin
that's what ruined god's creation sin
i don't say it's a little sin no picking
a fruit was a little sin
it had gargantuan consequences
shall we not recommit our lives to our
creator
our savior
who values us so highly the most
expensive thing
in the universe is not creation
not physical creation it is spiritual
creation
it is the salvation of one soul
that's you and so this morning
i ask god to receive me as i recommit my
life to him
it's his by right by creation salvation
and i say father use me
that through me someone at least one
may come closer to you and me to live my
life with the consciousness
that you've placed a value on me that
does not engender pride
but tremendous humility that the god of
heaven would value me so highly
the more highly i see my value to you
father let it deepen my humility
who will recommit the life to god
seriously and without any reservation
can i see your right hand
do you mean that hands down
is there someone who's drifted from god
you've drifted from your savior and you
know it right here
you know it god knows it the church
doesn't because you see you keep coming
to church
they can answer your heart you have
drifted from god
you want to come back
is there anyone like that you have
drifted from your god
i see that hand is there anyone else
like that
god bless you anyone else is that a hand
god bless you i see that hand those of
you who raise your hands i want you to
stand
i won't call you just stand where you
are i want to pray for you
specifically my call is i have drifted
from god
i've been committing murder and robbing
banks but i have drifted from god
and i want to come back seriously
never leave my god again
just stand where you are if you raise
your hands stand where you are
the rest of us had bowed eyes closed
our father in heaven we bow in your
presence there god
we're just dizzy cannot understand
how the great god as melchizedek refers
to him
in genesis 14 verse 20 and verse 19 the
possessor of heaven and earth
could value us so highly
father in heaven all we can do is offer
our
meager human tainted thanks
thank you dear god for loving us
thank you for sending your son
someone equal with yourself
the one who created for you who
maintains for you
he was the one who died on that cross
sweat great drops of blood why
for the salvation of one miserable soul
that's me
father in heaven open our eyes as david
prayed
in psalm 119 verse 18 open thou mine
eyes that i may behold wondrous things
out of thy law thy word
father increase our appreciation of how
much you love us hello white writes
that god loves the person who obeys his
commands
as he loves his son but john 17 23 says
the same thing
and so god in mercy you hear this
prayer from this sinner
your sons your daughters have stood to
say i have drifted
and i'm coming back and coming back
because when someone drifts from god the
person goes to satan
because father life is a life of
opposites this is the you are satan
we are for you against you we shape our
goats have no hell
give them an infilling of your spirit
right now
to sustain them in this decision that
the devil hates but that is causing
heaven to rejoice
let no power on earth their god change
their minds
lift them up now before the universe
father
and take all the glory we thank you for
this weekend
we thank you for the ministry of secrets
and sealed
continue to work through pastor poor to
unseal secrets that need to be opened
that the eyes of your people they god
may be opened that we may see the truth
and that the truth may break the last
fetters that satan has placed on us
every family father their family is
struggling
you know that bless the children
bless the children more than you bless
the parents that's my prayer
give them a double portion of your
spirit their god
heal broken marriages
father sometimes the greatest
expressions of loneliness are found
among married people
father let the marriage relationship
reflect that between christ
and the church give us a love for that
which is spiritual day god
your word the writings of ellen white
the writings of the pioneers
give us a love for that and that this
tastes for the world if there's someone
we need to forgive
give us the heart of jesus to forgive
that person
if there's someone to whom we need to
apologize give us the mind of christ
that we may have the courage to say
sorry however much it humiliates us
father let no one in this room be lost
when you come with your son
now dear god let us leave reflecting on
what we've heard
have mercy on me use me god
to speak your word fearlessly boldly but
with the consciousness that i'm a sinner
but a sinner who loves you and wants a
place in your kingdom
and loves your word and will go anywhere
you send him
hear this humble prayer father when you
come and you're coming
when you come save every one of us
every family member everyone for whom
we've prayed
into your kingdom i offer this prayer
from my heart
in jesus name and for his sake let god's
people say
amen and amen god bless you
god bless you